good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in the senate judiciary
committee yesterday marcia blackburn of
tennessee asked joe biden's supreme
court nominee contangi jackson which
should have been the easiest question
ever posed can you define what a woman
is
now imagine put yourself in her position
and imagine how relieved jackson must
have been when she heard that question
here she stayed up all night trying to
memorize obscure case law for the 19th
century in court precedent and when she
finally gets to the hearing room all the
republicans want is a recap of day one
of ninth grade biology what's a woman
for a world famous scholar like contangi
jackson that should have been effortless
talk about slow and steady right down
the plate a woman jackson might have
said looking incredulous
that's simple a woman is a human being
with two x chromosomes ask any
geneticist it's detectable in a blood
test
but if you're still confused by what a
woman is you can ask a doctor women have
wider pelvises and different bone
structures for men not to mention very
different genitalia
it's usually pretty obvious they're
women just by looking at them women are
built differently because their bodies
are designed to do different things
nature is real
women menstruate women give birth and
then breastfeed men do not do these
things because they can't
not a single man in all human history
has ever had his period or delivered a
baby and i know this senator
because i'm a woman myself
in fact that's why i'm here joe biden
nominated me to the supreme court
because i am female and he has said so
himself many times the president knows
exactly what a woman is if he didn't
know he wouldn't have picked me
obviously so please senator blackburn do
not waste my time with all respect that
is an incredibly stupid question
imagine if she said that what an answer
that would have been do you know a
single person wouldn't have cheered we
would have
honesty is a wonderful thing to watch no
matter where it comes from
but that is not what contangi jackson
said he was her actual answer
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
oh i'm not a biologist you're following
this so only a biologist is allowed to
tell you what a woman is and contangi
jackson incredibly impressive as they
tell us she is is not she just reminded
us a biologist
not that would make any difference if
she were a biologist because no one the
democratic party cares what biologists
think about biological sex biologists
have been banned along with a lady who
writes harry potter novels
in 2022 the power of science and
literature crumble in the face of the
trans lobby
so actually kentangi jackson's academic
credentials are not strictly speaking
all that relevant here
but still
pause for a second and marinate in the
awe-inspiring stupidity of her answer
what's a woman i don't know i'm not a
biologist oh
we see how this works hey contingency
jackson is it raining i don't know i'm
not a meteorologist
how would you respond to someone who
said something like that you'd probably
give up and find someone else to talk to
that person was not capable of
conversation
so last night we said we wanted to see
contangi jackson's lsat scores that's no
longer necessary we can say with
certainty she is clearly a sub-genius
and probably shouldn't be on the supreme
court
what's a woman
definitely the most revealing question
ever asked in a senate confirmation
hearing
and one of the many things it reveals is
how utterly the democratic party as an
institution has changed in just four
years it's a mile marker that tells us
the evolution of the party
so during the last supreme court
nomination you'll remember we were
commanded to believe that all women
must be believed regardless of whether
or not they were telling the truth
they're women therefore the name of
social justice you must accept whatever
they say at face value a woman's word is
like a sworn affidavit you can take it
to the bank here's kamala harris to
explain
let's speak truth about what we've all
been talking about the last few days and
again this evening which is that supreme
court process
let's speak the truth it was a sham
[Applause]
and a disgrace
let's speak the truth that it was a
denial of justice for the women of this
country
how amusing is it to see kamala harris
say let's speak the truth
throw a beer can at the tv if you agree
so to recap in 2019 it was quote a sham
and a disgrace to doubt a woman's word
because by the virtue of their biology
women did not lie that's what it was to
be a woman utterly truthful all the time
joe biden agreed with this women were
very different from men inherently he
told us so and that's why you weren't
allowed to hit them watch
we in fact have to fundamentally change
the culture
the culture of how women are treated no
man has a right to raise a hand to a
woman in anger other than in
self-defense and that's rarely ever
occurs and so we have to just change the
culture period and keep punching at it
and punching at it and punching it
all right so we mocked him keep punching
at it domestic abuse it is we made fun
of him but he was onto something
actually what he said was entirely true
ask yourself two men get in a bar fight
one of them punches the other in the
face what's your response to that come
on guys take it outside
a man and a woman get in a bar fight the
man punches the woman in the face what's
your response to that
well if you're a normal human being
you're horrified punching a woman in the
face is not just a felony though it is
it is a moral crime
decent people don't punch women in the
face
period
a man's best instinct is to protect
women that's nothing to be ashamed of it
makes a civilization civilized that's
why we don't send expectant mothers into
battle
got that you degraded freaks pregnant
flight suits
are an attempt to make us deny our most
basic instinct an instinct that we
should not be ashamed of
joe biden had this instinct he noted it
he was absolutely right why was he right
because when men and women are not the
same
we're not saying one is morally better
than the other they're morally equal but
they're different on the deepest levels
beginning with biology every person on
earth knows this is true we are born
knowing it
but now they're commanding you to
pretend otherwise to deny nature and
suppress your most basic and valuable
instincts they're telling you you have
no right to be more upset when a woman
is injured or a woman gets your ear
bitten off in a bar fight than when a
man does
are you ready to suppress those
instincts are you ready to live in a
society that won't acknowledge them what
happens to our justice system if we
pretend men and women are exactly the
same or don't exist
can tangie jackson's claim that we can't
say who's a man who's a woman will
transform the way we administer justice
starting with our vast regime of
anti-discrimination law
if we can't say for certain who's a
woman
how are we going to enforce joe biden's
famous violence against women act why do
we have such an act who would care
how can we set aside a huge percentage
of federal contracts for women-owned
companies if we don't know what a woman
is oh i guess that scam is going to have
to end tomorrow because it no longer
makes any sense
and by the way how is sexism even a
meaningful category in a world in which
sex has no meaning well it's not
why have title ix which bans sex
discrimination in schools if we don't
have biological sex how can we have
discrimination on the basis of
biological sex thinking this through the
trump administration thought it through
actually they saw this coming we should
tell you that the trump white house
tried to preserve title ix by arguing
that the concept of sex as defined in
that law derives from biology not from
how you're feeling about your personal
identity on any particular day that's
the case they made in response to that
they were denounced as right-wing
lunatics the aclu declared that quote
the trump administration is trying to
erase trans people
really maybe it was bigger than that
now the body administration is in charge
of everything and in less than a year
the worst most fervid predictions have
come entirely true female athletes are
losing ncaa championships to men
dressing up as women in order to cheat
their way to victory
every person in america sees this
happening
very few are brave enough to say a word
about it but here's one of them this is
a woman who happened to be watching an
ncaa swimming championship in which a
male swimmer going by the name of leah
thomas dominated every woman in the pool
i'm a woman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god don't be ridiculous
we'd love to have her on i'm not a vet
but i know what a dog is
yes you do we all do
even contangi jackson knows she's had a
few children of her own she probably
learned exactly how the process works
the point of the trans movement isn't to
convince anyone that biology isn't real
they're not even trying that's an
impossible case to make you would sound
ridiculous if you tried to articulate
that much less explain it the point of
this exercise is very different the
point is to make the rest of us repeat a
lie to say something we know perfectly
well is not true yes leah thomas is a
proud beautiful woman who won the swim
meet because she practiced harder than
the other girls lia thomas deserved to
win her victory wasn't cheating and no i
don't notice her bulging swimsuit i have
no idea what you're talking about
that's what they demand you say not
because they care about leah thomas or
any other trans person they could care
less
making you pretend to believe something
you don't that's the point because if
they can make you pretend to believe
something you know is untrue they've won
they control your brain
so this isn't about trans people it's
about all of us and the stakes are very
high and that's why the censorship is so
intense have you noticed
our national conversation about
transgenderism is completely defined by
censorship by making you shut up not
allowing you to notice the obvious is
why they're doing it there's no attempt
to persuade you there's no facts based
argument
you can't respond oh so men can become
women just by wishing it so tell us how
that works can i stop male pattern
baldness the same way can i grow six
inches please explain how this
remarkable new power the trans community
has discovered might apply to me
can i do it too
the power of positive thinking
well that's a fair question
they'll never answer it they'll just
make you be quiet their first move
always is censorship and their second
move inevitably is punishment we learned
that again last night when we were
suspended from twitter quote we have
determined that this account violated
the twitter rules specifically for
violating our rules against hateful
conduct twitter wrote to us the only way
out of twitter jail was to delete our
tweet to pretend we never said it
to cleanse america's
conscience by just
whiting out the past what was our crime
by the way well we dared to highlight
two accounts that twitter has banned
from charlie kirk and the babylon b
there's nothing hateful about either one
we'd say look them up but you can't
because they're gone now but both merely
noted that biological sex is fixed at
birth this has been universally
acknowledged by homo sapiens for at
least 300 000 years so it was a factual
statement
but on twitter as in our public life
truth is no defense
twitter is now run by a man called
prague agarwal who has said plainly he
does not believe in free speech agarwal
came to this country as an adult to get
a degree from stanford now agarwal
controls the single most important forum
for america's political conversation
that is a big and important job it's not
just a public company it's much more
than that it's a kind of public trust
that allows this democracy to function
so you would think you'd want a guy like
that in a position like that to have
some respect for his adopted country's
core institutions beginning with and
primarily the first amendment
but agarwal has no respect for a first
amendment or a constitution he explained
that openly in a 2020 speech watch
our role
is not to
be bound by the first amendment but our
role is to serve a healthy public
conversation and our moves are
reflective
of things that we believe lead to a
healthier public conversation the kinds
of things that we
we do to what about this is
to focus less on thinking about free
speech but thinking about how the times
have changed
one of the changes today that we see is
speech is easy on the internet most
people can speak where our role is
particularly emphasized is who can be
heard
oh so the new standard isn't your right
as a citizen to say what you believe is
true
the new standard is achieving something
called healthy public conversation by
the way this is not one man's opinion
you grew up in a country where people
were free to say what they wanted but
now that political speech in fact all
speech is disseminated to other citizens
via
social media
this is the guy who actually controls
what you're allowed to think
so what is healthy public conversation
what does that mean exactly we're
interested so we texted agarwal very
first thing this morning and then we
emailed his office and then him
personally all to find out agarwal was
too cowardly to respond to us so we're
going to have to assume that a healthy
public conversation is whatever prague
agarwal wants it to be
he decides the meaning in other words a
single man
who has total and undisguised contempt
for america's most basic values gets to
decide what americans are allowed to
talk about
craig agarwal doesn't think you should
know about hunter biden's laptop that's
unhealthy so he censors the story you
don't get to see it he doesn't think you
should be allowed to discuss basic
biology in public we're erasing all
science because it's unhealthy so now
you're not allowed to talk about it in
fact you're banned silence censored
we can't control prague agarwal but we
can't ask how do you feel about this new
standard
not so long ago this was a free country
now prague agarwal and nine other
billionaires whose names you might not
even know who certainly were not elected
to anything get to determine the limits
of your conversations are we okay with
this
what happened to all the liberals and
the self-described civil libertarians we
used to have in america they don't seem
to be fighting the power anymore they
seem to have joined it how about liz
cheney and adam kinzinger and everyone
else who's constantly lecturing the
surfs about democracy
is this the kind of democracy they're
talking about a democracy in which a
tiny sliver of very rich people control
everything including your mind
doesn't sound like democracy it sounds
suspicious like oligarchy don't you
think
they can let us know
all those people are welcome on that
this show anytime including and very
much including you craig agrawal we
promise a healthy public conversation
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else